last month so I just think I've been
quite active do you feel like yeah yeah
most mostly serve as well now I'm in
physio I can focus a lot more on comment
good time because today if I was in
training I wouldn't be able to come
today yeah so zone because I'm in rehab
so I could like negotiate with the
physio that can I get a date to come
down here when Ian's when are you next
supposed to be on the pitch on the pitch
probably in about two weeks maybe yeah
- we can start running and yeah nice
good so talk to me about strategy he
talked to me about how I can yeah I've
been back and forth a lot yeah in my
school's last month
yeah I already seen I feel like I've
been here before girl seen so many
videos yes oh they're the new be finding
deals and Johnny I see I've seen like
I've been to customers before
yeah obviously not saying I have to go
down and do it yeah like people you had
on as well at first Ryan was on and I
was like come see Samuel I understand
and when he styles I know it's guys this
was bad yeah when you came was good man
this is really inspirational as well
like the energy comes off with and you
guys come off with and the things you
say and this is great experience fun
okay so you're on the Academy yeah you
go out to do a whole series of training
programs yeah why what do you want to
get help me in this in this session it's
kind of kind of to set a plan really and
kind of get me focused on certain things
I feel like I'm
position is a bit hard because when
you're starting from throwing up with no
money whatsoever it's kind of you kind
of know what - it's a bit more
straightforward you're gonna go forward
like rent to rents the type of thing
like when you have a bit to invest with
it's nothing hard because I don't know
what to go into so you got something to
lose just crazy try to render engine
packages up this but if you've got oh
now you have choices
yeah sometimes is a bad thing because
choices sometimes leads to what they
call it a power paralysis by analysis so
how much do you have do you looking to
invest right now so right now okay cool
the ones I mentioned to you I mentioned
to you that the crash courses that
beforehand I bought properties that the
money's not working that well in it just
like after I learned about return on
investment so what's our god yeah it's
like three four percent so I'm just put
both them on the market
yeah literally last week two weeks ago
so hopefully when I get that output a
lot more to go with again so yes you're
selling a house as well as you do
okay and how much will that give you if
I get the price up my asking price
probably give me one off that paper
dollars off four six nine and then place
hub and Kings Cross and you'll say it
the full six nine you say no no that's
not my dad mortgage yeah and yeah I want
in Liverpool I would get about 145 K
after I sort of that but the London ones
looking a bit difficult to sell the
Liverpool one I think I'm Dupree easing
you in a really good place but I totally
get what you're saying you gotta use
smart yeah because you only bus do it
really well there I think straight away
a couple things I want to say number one
is I would want home 4% you wanted to do
put your money in pull your money out
deal so I don't this to you before yeah
yeah so rather than just investing it
you could buy like 10 or maybe a lot
more
yeah mom or you could buy like a load of
little single-a houses and then Matt but
actually I don't know if that would
really be smoke yeah yeah because one
deal I smelled in the big deal because I
actually when I first died I've got some
giddy I put like four offers own four
offers in on single their houses on
single-family houses and I pulled out
after I learned a little bit more I'll
pull it out yeah I said then I spoke to
you the cross-court you said no probably
just hold on a minute don't go by in a
minute and to learn a little bit more so
that's the stage I might now yeah okay
so what's the long-term goal and so
you've got you've got you've got you've
got a substantial amount of money to
invest we know that number one we want
to do it in they're gonna put your money
employee money away yeah number two we
don't want loads of houses and thanks
yeah what's the like saying in a year's
time or in three years time even what's
the what was the loans wonder what's as
a property investor what's lifestyle
look like because again some people say
I don't want to be involved when it can
be 100% passive for me it's purely an
investment like in put my money in do it
and then I just see incapacity think I
don't want to actually but then other
people actually know what I would see
myself as grooming a property business I
want to have a team I want to be in
debate so so I guess that's just one
question but like long term what's the
long-term goal for you what does life
look like on the property side I think
the long term goal is that do you wanna
be really hands-on in in properly so I
do want to have my own teams for now
clearly I don't have the knowledge to
manager so a minute I would get places
and properties and have a managed but
being the loop of everything so I can
learn at the same time yeah cuz I'm yeah
I do plan on having a full on property
business and especially when I'm
finished playing I think all so when you
go into into property what how's things
going because we spoke about the
property that you found you know the
student accommodation deal yeah yeah
feedback helpful yeah it was it was it
was it was it was really helpful it was
that's what it was I wanted to go that's
what I wanted I think that's why I
wanted you in my portfolio a lot of
apartment billions and I wouldn't I
really want to do big deals I'm I mean
terms of like aggressive I'm quite
fearless at times I will just kind of do
it I need fearless is good but
recklessness is bad
yeah the biggest thing that you could do
wrong because you can lose money
property yeah and you can't and I'm
obviously this too before but you first
deal what you do you often and I told
you remember I said no buying when we
met the crash course I was like please
do the training let's meet up yeah
do not buy anything which is contrary
advice and I want to take massive action
just go because that's what some people
need to hear but with you you've got
money and you need to really play it
right yeah cuz like don't buy anything
go for the training
let's physically meet in person
one-on-one here and I think what we
talked about was that you do often make
mistakes on your first day also on the
area and if your first deal is in the
millions which which it could be
leveraged with if you give you use back
too many return that you will and you
make mistakes that could be really bad
yeah as if it's a hundred Manhattan
today so the question is do you start
small and build up I think probably not
I think you just get the training and
support and you do a big deal straight
off but just do it very carefully risk
assess every step of the way nothing
that's we could talk about now yeah and
things like that
okay so long term goal is I guess like
why do you have your own team do you are
you running the business yourself I you
like what does I want to really
visualize yeah so I think I'll just say
it was real quick like everything
everything we work backwards on so it's
coming out what's the end goal and
they're making it more plan to get there
yeah that's why this is reform so I
think for me is it's a I really like I
think yours wasn't a big scar in that
training courses and you know that but
the way you do things I really like how
you have your
teams and you have people that will that
know what you do so ones bring new deals
and you have your portfolio you have a
big mixture of things don't you book the
cross or one your single lips so I do
kind of want a mixture of things and
just have the knowledge just kind of do
everything be able to do everything
yeah so I think my main thing I would
like to do big apartment buildings
that's why I want most of my income is
coming from because they're good good
business model as well why apartment
buildings what's the what's the
attraction to pollen buildings so things
what is what it's what you said is I
think have an apartment buildings may be
the same energy as having one house mhm
so I think rather than having loads of
houses scattered around I mean oh the
dog house is just in one area yeah and
what we all look to do is build upon the
box yeah I think most likely or all
convert an old horrible I mean we're
looking at a moment in fact I'm happy to
do take them out and come look at it
we're looking at buying a big plot of
land that's got an old hospital well I
don't know about this no no no it's an
old NHS building and now it's kind of
run-down so we're looking to buy the
piece of land we're gonna knock down the
building it's a big building yeah and
then build build a big block of
apartments yeah assuming that the
figures stack what you're going through
at the moment or then be able to
refinance pour all the money that we put
down out rent it out so you know I think
um from it got all our money back and
then and and I actually find I don't
know if you played the game cosplay 101
no dude that gabber it's like a get yeah
you all send you that give me the post
okay like that down you know when I read
the book your place no no you need to
you know exhorted to send him in the
post cashflow 101 what they see when you
play cashflow 101 is but it's a lot
monopoly but Robert Kiyosaki human in
the game's life we find is that not only
are big deals more profitable but
actually the profit margins are better
yeah so if you're doing a small deal
like a residential house putting your
money and pointing him in the alleys
vapor so Baba sometimes sometimes it's a
bit more difficult to pull all your
money out you might be represent out
with big deals it's easier yeah because
also you can afford to get the all the
surveyors or you can afford to do
because on a big scale yeah and the
profit margins are actually higher yeah
in big deals
not just the property the product
margins Highwood big deals no that's
that's that's what I want to be they're
talking about one of you yeah yeah to do
it okay we said just being able to
recognize the old hospital and that you
could make something called that yeah
that's what I want to get to you yeah
okay cool and we can talk about that and
how to find the tops of deals and it's
about team as well of course you know so
okay cool so palm of buildings or else
you say you want a team you wanna what
we mentioned about me speaking and being
branded yeah I mean do you wanna be
known as like Kevin property guy do you
want to have a brand do you want to cuz
if you do I can help you with that
yeah yeah I would definitely what's even
just like since I put a picture up with
you on Instagram mmm but property
investor in my bio that's from your
advice just you say Blair well you know
what you wanna do then you just get
people contacting you and the people I
spoke to in property so far I've been
like the best people sometimes they just
calling me saying ah I can see you're
starting property you wanna chat let me
know I've called a few people as opposed
to a few people
mm-hmm and you've had some really big
players and stuff reaching out to you
yeah yeah and he's awesome as well I can
you will I think when you tell the world
and you put it out that's why
that's why idea that's why I'm recording
this conversation yeah because I'm
constantly telling people what I'm doing
what I'm up to you what's happening yeah
and what happens is then suddenly you
start instead of having to go look for
deals and there's stuff Harmons gonna
look for - yeah yeah and the deal he
found was okay but it was yeah yeah the
figures were very optimistic on every
angle yeah
was it a bad deal no but was it a great
deal potentially not yeah when the area
and some of the dude rooms that we did I
thought you know so I wouldn't advise
Tara would I buy it but that's that's
the importance of young people you can
chat with you I think the main reason of
sending that to you was to see what we
do it looks like so if you said to me
yet an amazing building I know what it
looks like you said it's good buy
something risky because now I know why
one looks like have you said about it
you know it's funny that people think
I'm a massive optimist
I'm actually not actually real pessimist
when you need to be yeah yeah I'm an
optimist in terms of P but I believe in
people and believing the best of people
not come on easy anyone to do it and
whose are you use make you say but
actually when I'm couldn't you my
numbers I'm like worst case yeah I'm the
biggest pessimist I'm like hmm you know
so I think you do need to be yeah I
because the optimist sometimes when it
comes to investing in development and
stuff the optimist will lose and the
pessimist the pessimist is prepared to
take massive action yeah when needed to
will win
it's okay brand may that's a really cool
brand and I think I think it's a good
thing and the thing is well that you
need to be careful offering brand is
known actually when to say now yeah
because if you got all these people
coming to you and I get it I get
hundreds of messages a day again in the
same way when you've got money it gives
you a choice when you've got a brand new
gives your choice yeah because I I can
work with all these deal sources like
all these and suddenly all the people
are coming in it's like which one yeah
so how do you separate from the ones
that you want to work with what what is
it about them
do that they bring or yeah so from a
deal sources perspective and I think it
makes sense to buy from dual sources
potentially what I'm going to look for
number one it makes sure that they are
backed by a backed by the property
Ombudsman so if something goes bad
you've got black ink number two what is
there refer always there a they just
caught out the Woodworks yeah they just
someone on Facebook
he's been who's been on who's better
foes read a free book and they also sing
was just someone that's actually serious
you know had the training yeah I would
probably stick with people on the
Academy yeah already I've met admit I've
reached out to some people met some
people
I only do business you Academy members
pretty much it's not like a rule with
pretty much yeah yeah at least I know
where that come from I know that you see
the good training also I think as well
is just I'm actually happy with the
contracts so if they're saying oh I want
10 grand up front and then if the deal
falls out of bed will hey so we're
saying yeah no actually like you need
you need to work me on this little bit
when I'm doing big deals I usually like
to pay a percentage of front and then a
percentage actually a born either
completion or on the refinance okay okay
you know it's like listen if you believe
in the deal that bad yeah you know then
how about I'll pay you X now and then
I'll pay your percentage of the profit
yeah so did you say majority of your
deals now coming from dual sources I
have full-time deal sources to work
exclusively for me alright so I have
like sometimes I do like a salary about
all partnership yeah but but yeah so
they're there for instance all of my big
deals come from been okay did you mean
been no I'll get you to meet men yeah
he's on six figures six figures baseline
and then he gets his property share and
he does all the project management all
that kind of thing he found the NHS okay
they chartered chartered surveyor cost
manager really knows his dough
so was he could you do it with this
before you met him yeah turned off I
mean he's been in property for he's been
in construction for 16 years I was
longer than I have
but then we brought our skills together
so okay you know I mean you know I can't
ever you all didn't it
what's that come together really well we
meeting your wife and he has a problem
well my wife just say that yeah so
that's where I get my deal strong no so
and then he project manages it if you
want to meet Ben definitely in fact what
we should do
I will bring you I'll let you come when
our next on the road a band viewing some
potential deals just helping you along
you know I'll be you know amazing yeah
you'll probably get more on that than
even yeah yeah yeah today's gonna be
great obviously but we can do some
business
I'm always open you know or if not you
can just learn see what we're doing yeah
and how do you how do you cost manage
this and how do you know because
ultimately you've only got to know those
three things that we talk about number
one purchase price number two
development and number three don't value
that's it that sounds it sounds easy
please really hard yeah but if you can
get those three figures yeah yeah like
that deal that you looked at saintil
store but but yeah and I think you need
to be looking stuff when you putting
them on yeah and they need that thing
you showed me was just put your money in
leader money and yeah yeah whereas you
want to be putting your money into
cording you money now
yeah hundred percent and that's majority
of them are ones we have to do a lot of
forceful you up yeah and how do you
force to buy it by becoming more
valuable yeah and you have a set team
that doesn't it doesn't matter yeah one
team yep goes ever right yep well pretty
much been hit been hit it up yeah but
yeah we ought we have a team so it's not
necessarily the same team so the castle
he's been project managed my castles
been project mines my team Ben's
overseeing that yeah and then I've got
my Lincoln project we just build six
houses from scratch that had a project
manager but been over spend got oversees
the project managers yeah okay cool yeah
I think so that's one thing I need to
think about doing his own having a team
that does that I don't know anything
about how to drop out
so having a team in place with
definitely give me more confidence and
really go and please deal was because I
know that I can just get them in once I
want to have one I think for you I would
be really really cheesy yeah I'll be
like ridiculous the juicer you know
honestly my advice that I plates up to a
lot of people you know take action take
action which is so true because if
someone's got no money just books and
viewings yeah but for you you're going
man you're going to do stuff you meeting
me you join the Academy your problem is
not that you are not taking action like
for you I'd be like really cheesy yeah
you know what
the first if when you come out with me
and ban on the road you're gonna be
wanting to buy some deals you're like
wow like oh my goodness can i buy that
you're gonna move you want oh I don't
wanna be like no yeah you know yeah I
would like come next month and see
what's on the table make smoke yeah
because believe me there's enough deals
it's not a case of when when it's like
it married you marry the first girl that
you'd meet when you do a big development
projects big deal so I just feel like
I'm gonna just take my time you know I'm
gonna go out and Samuel see some
projects then I kind of get an idea of
what at the moment you don't know what a
good deal looks like yeah you know so
when you get to say okay this is an
average that that's good and then when
the right one comes along and it could
be three weeks it could be three months
it could be six months doesn't really
matter yeah because you don't need you
don't need a deal in the next three
months you're thinking over the next ten
years or even yeah you children yeah or
children's children like this is the
long-term game so probably way to choose
it yeah I think I think with the things
going on like bricks and things like
that
yeah something in my head that just give
me a real like urgency that I kind of
need to get into because I feel like
zombies Jassa can happen you know I mean
it's probably cuz my mind a little bit
listen I get that my great I think that
that with brexit come in so I think it's
a very good opportunity right now at the
same time you don't want to you
want to make a decision based on rush
and also when you're you're excited when
emotions are high intelligence is low
yeah yeah okay so you could you could
literally buy something and put down you
know 300 300 grand we do a deal and then
and then it's like actually next month
it's like it's a good deal I wish I
bought that one yeah but you just got
started you literally it's like if you
go into a shopping mall you know you
might want to just you know you want to
eat still nice dinner let's have a
little look at the restaurants and then
let's make up our mind you don't miss
the first restaurant I'm gonna be in it
yeah I think I'm gonna come down with
that the emotion when I said I'll output
offers in about $4,000 are keen on and
they pull it out and then yeah I'm gonna
calm down but you can go view them yeah
go to go to an auction and don't buy
anything yeah and do it just see and
learn and the discipline of not bring on
something because honestly I've seen
people lose because they've just I've
just gone too quick yeah too fast and I
know it sounds very contrary to what
people would expect me to say but but
this because most people's problem is
that they're [ __ ] and you're not yeah
I'm ready man yeah your problem is that
you you'll be to the next deal sauce
that comes along and offers you an
opportunity usable yeah man but you know
I was so good it cuz it takes so long to
buy something yeah that's what stopped
you from buying it if I could buy a
house it about a week I would've had
about I mean jeez good job with my I
don't that's why my youtubers I don't
encourage people to buy from auction I
bought from auction a lot yeah but I
know if I talk about behind from auction
what's gonna happen there's people that
watch my youtube they aren't on the
Academy you don't come to the crash
girls they're gonna get excited they're
gonna go to an auction but they're gonna
mess up come back and then they'll come
back and bite me you know it's just like
yeah you know so I think we need to be
neat with it we do need timelines you do
want to be able to say at this bite by
this date I want to something in the
back yeah or by this day I want to be in
a position whereby I feel like a
professional knowledgeable investor at
this at this point we can set dates and
stuff and set time runs and
check in with you and stuff yeah but but
this day I want to be at a point where
I'm like okay I've seen this many big
deals mm-hmm
you know by this day I've had this many
opportunities and said no yeah yeah yeah
that's kind of bye-bye this day I want
to have something in the back and by
this day I'm gonna have a property yeah
and that could be by the time you get
big and again with a big one like what
house you can serve you at all by behind
a hundred by residential house rody is
anyone just a normal yeah I think we may
be going through the motions of buying
one probably knowing what to do when you
that's probably right yeah I can tell
you what the motion is oh yeah I mean I
mean and also if you really want to if
you're I'm really itching to just do a
smaller orders to get more confidence
than I was following and some people are
scared to do big deals because they're
like mmm big deal like oh my gosh I feel
like I need to start small first and
I'll say what did happen yeah yeah I'm
really in the artists now you know I
mean like I think it's just the same the
numbers just bigger yeah yeah
to me the only thing I just calculate
the risk that's all as I would with yes
as long as I feel confident I know the
risks let's talk about de-risking stuff
so you say you know oh and my exit
strategies as well but yeah I want to
speak to about you mention our
strategies and you need best cases like
the case worst case worst case if this
exit strategy happens I'm one you're
gonna lose my yeah and if you're not
gonna lose money even if there's the
worst worst case yeah sometimes you need
an exit strategy and then you need an
exit to the exit strategy
yeah really because we're not talking
about buying a buying a hundred-man
house and bringing out by the room isn't
it cool when they can end with a quit
amount of profit whoa like we're not
doing about that we're talking about
when you put in and you've worked hard
for this yeah hard you know so we're
talking okay we saved up this money did
you
come from football yeah and respect
because I bet a lot of your friends have
been spending and yeah yeah no that's
one thing I'm not a big spender good
tool right and and you know what as well
when you do become a big spender which
you big spender you can spend the money
from your profits of your property
business yeah so all the passive income
that you get and you can go crazy with
that but you know I like about the
property money is that I feel like yeah
I've earned that by just doing doing it
just playing football and doing what I
like doing
but for that property is what you made
it you've made the money yourself I mean
I mean if someone's giving it to me for
favorable yeah I like the fact that like
like an intrapreneur on and a
businessman they make money themselves
that's always what I've wanted to do
mmm-hmm I'll just make it from from me
what are you more both about like you
wanting to grow your net worth and
become wealthier you want in a certain
amount of cash flow so you know that if
you got injured or whatever you know
that you got like what's the no I think
it's well I've always wanted to even
when I finish playing football make more
money in then I'd do playing football
it's just like a challenge I can't see
myself just retiring and kind just
living off what I made I just really
like challenges and I really like doing
put myself out there taking risks I just
this is why I like doing it so I can't
imagine myself retiring and just you
know just being a really low profile and
low risk and just kind of live a full
life as well sister take change like the
generation that you come from that my
friends and my family we've all come
from really not much money and not have
to spend money not have to use money you
know some people can't come on holiday
because they ain't got no money as you
guys want to flip that yeah and really
like be now will you talk about be
valuable so I can teach people how to
make money as well because the more
people that could be trained one day
yeah Suze I don't think about for sure I
mean if you wanted you know I'm always
with trainers yeah yeah yeah I mean I so
even part of the comment on the training
course he's not necessarily for me
Clemmy not I don't think I'm gonna use
rental rents but I could do what not
rent to rent but no one had to do it and
be available to teach someone else have
to do it it's probably the main reason
why I love how you made your dad go on
the Academy oh yeah like that's sick
yeah because it's like because because
because most people I speak to
especially a lot of footballers they but
actually the best gift is it long
everyone family it was great but the
best gift you can give to a family yeah
is actually knowledge and also we've
rental reps and stuff like that one of
the things that you'll do but just know
you well is some of your properties you
will pass on to people as rent around
yeah let them keep the money but then
you have the guarantee you have the ease
when I was starting out in property I
was the guy that was like I want to get
my hands day over all the time I don't
have any money
yeah someone like talking to the
landlord's doing a guaranteed rent and
stuff like that because I just wanted
the 500 quid a month yeah or the ground
and month and a few those oh wow making
a full-time income I haven't gonna have
a job mm-hmm but now I'm the other guy
now I'm like I don't want to manage
properties I don't want to have the
tenants or people ringing me now I'd
rather not make it grand a month from
this deal I'd rather make five hundred
quid yeah so a lot of students for they
be doing rinse rinse on - yeah yeah now
they do
all my all my HMOs now I've passed on to
people as on regiments that's the major
calving yes that's it and some of them
make really good money yeah some of them
no I don't that I make two weeks money I
don't mind I'm still making good money
off of there hmm but you can have that
because because managing property
managers sometimes can be as bad as
managing tenants yeah yeah and when
you've got a lot of properties and a lot
of tenants like it's just so different
when you when you wanted to get out of a
nine-to-five job you only two or three
HMOs that might only be an hour's
management a week yeah potentially is
it's great compared to a job but like
just you know in terms of scaling and
small deals you can't one of the things
I've learned as well as
you took about team and stuff there's
not enough profit in small deals to
start employing people yeah it gets
tough
whereas I can't afford to pay someone
hundred thousand pounds a year to help
Oh to help project with the project
management of development stuff that's
in a million power I can't afford to do
that no problem I can't afford to pace a
good person 100 men a year to manage my
HMOs yeah because that's my profit
guards gone yeah I'm saying yeah yeah so
what what are the things that are gonna
what are the like I guess we look at the
the threat versus the opportunities the
the things that could potentially mess
you up this year like one of the things
whether it be a case if you lose you
lose motivation I don't mean Zach
remember this motivation or you do a bad
day or loved one of all the things what
things the problems concerns questions
challenges that we can really kind of
you know go through now to stop things
messing up and then we can fit I think
the only thing is just not rushing oh
yeah that's what I've done I've looked a
lot of stuff and a good night tonight
something really good comes along then I
might do it but still I probably
would've sent it to you anyways so yeah
just not rushing but now we're at that
point now sorry you can send me anything
by the way yeah you want to send me any
deals
would you look over all all my teams
look over it appreciate you know we'll
do that and and because I know last
thing I wanted you to buy just to buy a
lemon like that won't be so annoying and
it made me look so bad imagine that like
yeah oh come on equesticles doing the
Academy and then now do you notice all
right woman protect you as well as
inspire you to take action by you to do
well I also want to protect you from
from failing of course ultimately
everything you do everything you buy is
you and I can only I can only give you
pointers and stuff and give you you know
my mother advice from my experience okay
so not worsening we've totally got those
there anything else no not really the
only thing you know they're not in
Russian yeah what about when you go back
to football because of course and I says
you know yeah probably know most most of
them but what would you say when you
you've out of time off because you broke
the leg which is actually giving you an
opportunity to do all this anticipate
you become here yeah a couple weeks you
can get back into football what's gonna
happen in terms of like time and I think
you should focus mainly on the football
look the footballs with him there's got
it got us in this great situation now
like the football is 100% hands down the
thing that I think you should be going
on and then the property somebody do in
the side yeah I think because people
don't know how much spare time do you
have that's one thing
trouble is difficult yeah because ok
I'll maybe finish some training at 2:00
p.m. and then it's tough for me to get
two days off I think I'm flexible now
because I can negotiate with the days I
come in because I don't have to train
with the team and haven't got prepared
for a match but in terms of time in
terms of doing work doing do did due
diligence and calling people and all
that that's like I mean unless they're
in a they're very far away so think
about for I get home from training 2
p.m. for the rest of the day I'm kind of
kind of free and this time you get the
only thing is as well you don't really
know sometimes when days off for coming
so you can't plan that well yeah but in
terms of work and education you know
that like you've got so much time so
much time set up to build a business
yeah yeah ok
so one of the things that you need
really firm in and like today in order
to we don't if you do feel like God I
came up to London got a plan what do you
need from me I think I think just kind
of pretty my intentions are there no I'm
looking to do so you know so do you know
anyone else listening knows doing
anything will know what to give on open
so all of it yeah get a bit of exposure
you'll get bombarded and I'll be good
I'm willing to work with you I mean it
was crying especially people from the
Academy yeah so I think that and they
just having a real plan in place so I
know where to focus my energy on I've
got a lot of energy
probably right now I just need to know
where to put my focus on what to look
for where to look for yeah okay cool so
what I'd probably say is first thing is
I think you need to get in front of
opportunities I think you need to get in
front of development opportunities you
need to be getting in front of whether
that be from you know sources venture
partners friends people on the academy
you should be getting out there yeah so
control because I was like yes did I
look into big deals in Liverpool mm-hmm
regulate and says lots of people lots
people on the Academy so yeah it's going
down to you and that's why you want oh
you're here
but to be like put yourself out there
like wow I want to see some
opportunities I want to see some so what
would the feel looking at different big
deals development joint venture projects
sources what would be the ideal project
for you what would be like yes this is
this is like this is the dream project
because I when you speak it out you're
speaking into existence when you get you
know what you want and you're specific
it's more likely to come your way so I
think definitely for the first one it
would be two out with someone
mm-hmm no what they're doing a joint
venture for joint venture so for example
I met up with he was on here as well
yeah he took time out to meet me and
showed me his projects and because I was
interested in in like development and
apartment buildings which he which he
does yeah so yes for him so he liked
what he was saying inspired me as well
as like she like I know I loved what he
was doing and but yeah so he already had
his budget sets on he's like an amine he
doesn't really have anything that
product could get involved with but yeah
working with someone like that who knows
what they're doing and you can teach me
as I wish yeah
I've lost deal but put myself out there
too much snow like if I deal with it
well I'm in the middle to do something
and then I'll put it out there and then
people will then gonna jump me okay
that's all right all right so but then
also I've made I've made a lot more
money from front so I think again when
you put yourself out there you just be
just do be mindful sometimes of just
like okay you know what could be the
worst case of this I think that's a big
thing we learned how to do a risk
assessment yeah I mean I mean with big
projects risk assessment so really
simple to the three figures so for
instance with this okay so this land
that we are looking to buying to build
on here's what his of his worst case so
here's an example what can go really
wrong so you see you see of CCA Portland
maybe I can build on it obviously need
to get Plan B wishing to build on it
yeah and then you buy the land and you
buy it for a million quid and then you
can apply for planning permission and
the Planning Commission's failed and
you're like oh man yeah Kahn
I mean I've been declined yeah and then
you end up with a Portland
you don't want you can't build on then
you have to get put the land back on and
then you realize it's actually reach off
to sell and it's just like yeah but
that's worst case all you buy a piece of
land in Bobby's land and then you get
planning planning comes back fine but
then you realize that your estimation of
how much it's gonna cost to build is
wrong
yeah you thought it was gonna cost a
half a million to build six hands in
such thing on customer million and then
the end value which was correct but
because you got the bill wrong you know
making no money you know and there's
nothing more demoralizing the working
than were 12-month project and build it
for free horrible like a lot of energy
goes into it when when you're building
houses from scratch and you know you're
gonna make a million quid Denny's
satisfying yeah when you build in six
houses they
you're gonna make nothing very very
demoralizing yeah so that's the problem
but but I don't want to be put on the
musicians all we do is we'll by piece of
land but what we'll say is we'll say
we'll buy it and we'll give you a
deposit of 20 grand but then we'll give
you the rest in six months right okay
and in that six months we're going to
get planning and there's and then the
other yeah
now that way what's that wasn't what's
the new worst case will the new worst
case tis that we can't get planning and
then we go oh man can't get planning
we've lost the deer we can't buy it and
we've lost our 20 grand
yeah so without it with my deals every
worst case is never going to [ __ ] me
yeah every worst case is just gonna hurt
a little
oh man I lost 20 grand no big deal yeah
oh I lost a million quid big deal yeah
so that's called de-risking so make
sense yeah yeah yeah so you buy the land
but you owe an option and you put money
down another way of de-risking a deal
this is something is Peter land because
this is another thing sometimes with big
deals cash flow could be a problem
yeah because if you put all your cash
into something and then you've got and
you can have money but if it's all tied
up
you know bankruptcy yeah yeah literally
can go bankrupt when you're playing with
big stuff if you don't forecast things
properly
yeah so something that we always try and
do is put down as little money as
possible if we can so we'll say okay
piece of land does the beast I'm looking
at the moment and then won't want me to
talk about where it is or anything okay
but all I'll say is it's in the Midlands
okay okay I know but anyway cool so it's
on for two million the the build is
going to be in several millions but the
gdv the aim values really hot yeah we
want the land for two million however
what we're doing in this case is we're
saying to the person that selling the
land
hey let rather than giving you two
million okay you can't struggling to
sell the time anyway because a few
issues will give you 2.2
but we'll pay you out of the profits
right yeah because they know they are
selling the land resentfully because
they know how much money cuz I could
make on it the reason they're selling is
because they haven't got the money
yeah and they can't get the money cuz
they're gonna have the people yeah I
have the brand the network the power of
the cash which we have hmm with the
money we have the brand we can raise the
money so they're like oh man I wish I
could build myself a home Louie okay all
put the money in let's do a joint
venture dog joint venture with the owner
yeah yeah yeah I got you that's D risk
in Kasumi you're not putting 2 million
into buying a piece of land and all the
risks on you you're saying to the owner
you're selling you've already got the
plan even right let's do a joint venture
not yeah you'll end up with more than 2
million yeah you just won't get it right
now yeah yeah so many yeah you're in
really pain it once you know successful
one is working if you're bridging and
bridging finance on something you got to
make sure that you know what the end
value is so we've been a big deals you
can afford to do this so will we will
get before the bought piece land in
Lincoln three hundred thirty thousand
pounds before we bought that we've
already had a week's valuers rapport
saying once you've built the six houses
this would be the value as long as you
build it to this standard so we already
had it
we're not getting yeah yeah you can't
guess you kind of feel like all I think
the houses in this street con when you
do these types of deals so we already
have the Rick's value upfront yeah then
the build from the builders you've
already got it you working with builders
you working with a one person who's
project managing the team you've got a
very clear itemized weight on everything
you've got the contingency plans in
place because because there's always
think there's always Oh preparing the
land is going to cost a next 100 grand
oh you know but but bill
he's much better than with Harry yeah
yeah so I'm straightforward yeah no I'm
a sense but I mean when you when you
when you can do all that and you're that
experience then I mean at the wrist on
the floor was bad once you know the risk
you're only playing with yeah when you
know where it is
you only play with 21 yeah yeah you've
only put 20 grand down you know you've
not put two million back yeah because
then you really exposed mm-hmm does that
make sense yeah yeah also as well also
as well if your mind to sell actually
we've done this where we've bought
property and the plan is to buy and then
just sell it off it the units off but
then the exit tragedies what was it
because we can't sell them we can we
find us so why would something you want
to sell one something you want to keep
and Rin well that would be the
difference okay so you if you want okay
so the pros and cons I guess all the
difference would be if you're buying
your property and the plan is to go
wrong
okay let's say you're buying a property
and you think I can't want to buy this
property or this piece of land I'm gonna
build some houses I'll sell them off
that's the plan and then you work out
that if you sell them off at the the
crisis you'll make five on your map what
we do but then when you come to sell
them you can't sell them because no one
wants to know me like man yeah you know
the value of them but you can't sell
them chick okay I'll refinance them but
we didn't work out worse actually these
properties are really bad by to less
you'd be financed them the mortgage
payments are so high the red won't even
cover it right does that make sense yeah
yeah so if your boat said bye to say the
roof people want to buy didn't build or
build to sell is because they just want
to they don't want to get a passive
income and just want to get chunks of
money yeah which is great and then with
that chunk somebody you can do you can
do you can get passive income but then
if you're doing that you need to say
what if I can't sell them
can I refinance them do the deals stack
as bio refinery builder briefed on it
yeah
does it still stack up what would be
even though I don't want to be fine
if I do we finance it what am I going to
be paying each month and just to rent
more than cover that yeah even though I
want to be fine so I want to sell it
because that way there's my exit
strategy mm-hmm you do not can you do
this with your property with the because
like there's no exit strategy yeah yeah
no your properties like this is
bellowing solely on the market and this
the university there's no eggs it
doesn't bring out well
it's built as this yeah because if I'm
doing an HTML I say well what would it
be like as a single that yeah yeah but
it's still stacking and is that is that
is that the same case with all the
pollen block so majority of them no I've
been not much better strategies what
about that exit strategies could a block
out I mean we're going to turn the cast
into apartment blocks right so so so so
and with that we're probably going to
sell them if not we're going to
reformats them and then we'll do it as
well we know that that workers service
combination yeah yeah so and then that's
was well when you learn things on the
economy much service commission but
actually it is number one for networking
but number two is a good property
investing is not all I think and it's
okay to have a fixed bar that's okay
people have a fixed plan and it's a lot
of developers that do this and I'm not
gonna not because I make a lot of money
but when you have a fixed plan you end
up turning away so many good stuff and
generally good but when you are actually
on quite open and I've got a general
plan but on property problem solver and
I'm going I know about simulation about
hmm assisted living another yeah that's
why I wouldn't be on the course yeah not
that maybe use it now but yeah just like
to have it just to have it you know what
you know interested in yeah dude yeah
I've been on the training I know all
about it and you
yeah rather than us thinking what if
yeah you know yeah it's a helpful
definitely in terms of action plan
because if you can't leave without an
action plan at all details before we get
there how you manage your selves and how
you manage everything yeah that for
example I wonder when it's autumn was a
like when you spoke about a meter that
you two went around Liverpool you just
fire you mere power in there how is that
your work-life balance you up to you to
kids
yeah yes I've met to have a second as
all we know rats in Feb yeah yeah so how
would you how would you manage that you
know I don't even believe yeah for me
I'm just like everything is I see my
family a lot yeah I'm on the road a lot
if an opportunity comes one I'll go view
it
I've probably submitted for in
footballers when you've got a train
you've ever play you got a black coat
rack yeah then you also have a lot of
downtime and days off there it's just
the same for me absolutely crazy not
mean like going to bed a fine because I
mean to all over the country mean new
meetings that I mean yes stepping on to
three hours sleep over the last few days
but then next week we'll probably be
I'll be working two or three hours a day
yes these guys just flow with it and
flow with it depending on what comes up
okay
and I've got a wife two kids yeah yeah
to recharge yeah and also put on the
team
so the Liverpool properties I've got a
team people bring him in the deals are
they've got people that will crunch the
numbers and think of people that will
book my day and make sure that
everything's lined up well you said to
be with us little boy and I was like
yeah I mean I dunno but it's just like
it just booked a woman I know I want to
go you want to grow like that where do
you mean you starting point but what to
do things don't necessarily and what
time for that you don't want you it's
that's am i earning and am i learning
yeah if I'm do something and I'm not
getting paid to do I don't mind if you
learn
yeah but I'm never gonna do something
mundane that I've done before a million
times when I could play someone else to
do it if I'm not growing doing exactly
yeah
do you ever it's all here just like you
missus have a lot of family down here
it's kind of funny been moved to high
wycombe to be near myself on even decks
like 15 minutes and he moved to be close
my brothers were a family
yeah we go 1-1 is why I wanted to ask
when I am want me to be 12 like a lot of
football is about finger investments and
what I want to do after and a lot of
them are actually in terms of what this
kind of in a quite skeptical about my
bio
yeah and they're really just a lot of
them have a finance advisor and it will
kind of say the same thing and it's all
like stocks stocks and shares is it so
if it was 20 footers right
why would you say property and not not
necessarily not talking sense Bob yeah
why would you bet property more than
main reason for me is leverage when you
buy stocks you got to put all of your
money into the style well yeah property
you can leverage so the return on
property the return cash on cash
investment just kicks the ass of stocks
yeah not only that but with stocks you
can't put your money in the stock and
then pour your money out and have a free
stock mm-hmm on it which stocks I'm not
knocking stocks but with Starks what
happens if the business goes bust
why does if you've invested in
businesses and then he's totally out
your control your property although to a
point you can say it's a control you buy
a property bricks and mortar and you can
see it touch it feel it it's there
that's gonna happen that's gonna outlive
your kids mm-hmm and we're on a small
island with an overpopulation of people
and a shortage of houses so ultimately I
think supply and demand so for me it's
just like yeah I think financial
advisors okay
again I've usually got an agenda and
very cautious listen to them for sure
can't speak to them but ultimately how
many people do you know that have got
really rich from their financial adviser
and how much is that financial adviser
worth why take advice from someone
that's net worth is worth almost zero
yeah yeah that's one thing I've realized
when I learn learning everything was
that like I told you I always had the
goal of growing not just maintaining or
living off Y over Y own and I just got
the vibe with a lot of fineness of a lot
of spoke to is its kind of really safe
put your money there just kind of live
off the 5% that you they from what
you've got and that's what I just just
not really what I want to do yeah and
also also you're not even in control in
the sense of are just tourists you some
things as something as important as this
yeah which is your money your life your
livelihood looking after your family why
just put that in the hands of some dude
yeah oh yeah I'll just give you all the
money and you tell me where to put it
like I want to learn this a lot
sometimes it depends on what your goals
on how you seize know but I think a lot
of people are not too bothered about
make it growing or making more money if
think they're just kind of happy to do
that which is the right base when they
say yeah they want to grow their mind
they want to do is they want to do that
but then they do something so small like
that or so conservative like that yeah
do you know what putting money into
stocks and the franchisor respect that's
better than spending it on yeah lights
out and fancy cars when terms of s and
so respect yeah however I personally
have never gone down that route yeah you
know and I'm speaking to everyone that
I've spoke to for whose use gone down
that road and then meets me he's like oh
my goodness that was actually that
didn't work out that well yeah not to
set all the lost of the new minima but
it's just like this is more time this is
better this yeah yeah and I'm not all I
am is a really good property investor
who happens to have a passion
help other people in property but yeah I
mean if there's on your annual annual
risk levels on your butt for me property
just wins and I go down I've you know
debates and stuff with people and and
and we talk about stocks or equity
versus property and I've never heard
anybody win the argument when they're
arguing for stocks yeah I just never
because I just think it's a weak
argument yeah I mean uh come here water
they made a good point that if you went
to a bank tried to get a loan to print
some stocks you wouldn't go back you did
buy property yeah yeah don't value
indicate yeah because they know what's
gonna happen they know it and probably
you get paid twice you get paid wanting
once in cash flow and once in a capital
appreciation yeah it was gonna stop
we're gonna just sit on it and like okay
you might get like a tiny yeah but I'm
in with other side anything is leverage
anything is pointy money in point money
out so yeah that's one as well how do
you always know well cuz showing it
every day but how do we know about when
the rules and property change so for
example I think you spoke a lot about to
refinance sometimes you have to wait six
months and then you thought everyone or
no now you can do it kind of straight
away yeah how would you always know when
okay so uh several ways number one is I
have regular meetings with more power
team so we want accountants my
solicitors my so my property managers so
if the rules doors licensing and stuff
is changing with properties because my
property management companies will tell
me yeah if it's a tax law my accountants
will tell me yeah if it's so so my team
I have regular meetings and chickens
they're ahead of the game they advise me
and they tell me what's what
secondly is I think because I am kind of
a public figure in this field in this
property space I can't not know because
people are getting on it yeah so people
were like saying what do you think of
the new tax changes and in my the rule
I've only happened an hour ago
maybe I've not had one meeting you have
my count over what Oh
what's that there go check it out so I
just can't
yeah cuz I'm so immersed in this field a
new space for me the changes I just I
just can't not know and then thirdly is
I have people I've people in my team
who's part or the whole double part of
their job is researchers so I've
researchers that just study they've read
the newspaper they and then they and
then they report to me you want even my
power ten so I'm really I'm really ahead
of the game and not just ahead of the
game but I made predictions and I'm
usually right yeah so I what like for
instance when the whole thing was going
on about with Jeremy Corbyn and I said
guys Jeremy Corbyn is not getting in
Labor's and it was about how do you know
that you don't never saw I'm not gonna
have pointless arguments about what if
this rule comes in it's not gonna come
in how do i I know stuff you know I'm in
the meetings I know stuff so and I'm not
being like arrogant or anything and I
want something always right on stuff but
but I'm usually right and I even says
the person who asked me the question
myself is publicly I said if Labour get
in and they're also know which of these
labor game tell me your favorite charity
nor donate ten thousand pounds yeah yeah
because everyone likes to make
predictions but all like literally look
yeah I'll put it out there I'll put
money on it so I'm not gonna worry about
things that might happen or might not
happen because usually I'm a pretty good
radar for predicting what's gonna happen
and a lot of that a lot that's based on
history and a lot that's also based on I
know it can't because feet it's not
feasible
yeah because most of the people that
make up the rules are the same people
that make money in property yeah so I'm
thinking life only ones that interest us
cuz some we go to 20 percent it's like
they're not gonna they're gonna go up
but they're not gonna because it would
bankrupt so many people who would ruin
the economy so he's just not gonna
happen they're gonna go up a little bit
but you can just do you can just dive
you can just don't risk risk assess it
you can just fix the interest rates for
10 years
yeah or you can just [ __ ] about how
they might go up and talk about what
happened in the 80s the ire you know
what I mean I just think it's really
important to be informed and it's really
important to have good people around you
and it
yeah okay come from when you put your
your first property 17 yeah did you ever
did you ever imagine this in terms of
training on the scale
no I've been business on the scale you
kind of just how did it come about
gradually so my property portfolio my
plan was that was just to become
financially free yeah so then free me up
to actually go and do a lot of charity
work and missional stuff yeah
became financially free started going
out going to Africa I set up a Christian
Business Network
because I was just passionate about and
I was doing all that stuff
and a lot of the people that I was
helping from a missional point of view
between know profit I was actually
losing money but I was doing it because
that was what my purpose was was saying
peach is about property right does its
diet so remember that yeah I remember
very first crash course in November 2014
and I ran it for the people from my
non-for-profit Christian business
network many how many were there oh I
think that about 20 I was ran it and I
actually need to get people off my back
because I'm looking one of one day
property investors crash course okay and
if you thought that was so good when you
do the next one I wonder send my friends
I didn't and another one and it wasn't
to 2016 when I thought you know what I'm
actually helping more people teaching
people about property though man we've
all the other stuff I've been doing so I
mean that's just a lot charity work in
Africa I go out we build wells and
thanks but when it does Jennifer can a
lot of the stuff I do is teach property
yeah
to the budding entrepreneurs and stuff
so I realized I was actually helping a
lot of people so now I don't it doesn't
16 looks like I'm really going hard and
what this is you know and then the
training business blow up I don't take a
salary from the training business so I
because I think that for me it's just
it's just important to say actually know
what all the profits that we make for
the training business I want to put I
want to back yeah into growing the
mission I want to put into charity and
and and ultimately I want to make I want
my salary from poverty that's that's my
love and I think it's also just anyone
that says like are you just you you only
teach people to make money it's just
like it totally takes that skeptic yeah
but even even if you did believe me I
know there's no problem in it it's a
service just like anything else I know
they're making money from as all yeah it
was with my brother about two years ago
when when the training business below
because he's a real smart businessman
and he put system systemized at ya and
scaled it and and that's what it really
blew but no I didn't expect this I don't
yeah yeah and then from from from when
you put your first house in than when
you started growing is in the property
investor you say your main strategy to
grow him was putting your money out all
the time and keep going that how you
regroup okay so the main wire grows
almost by mistake it was my property's
going up in value that's how you get
rich yeah and that's what they want in
one but I think for me I was getting
little properties I was making a bit to
cash flow oh wow that's fine actually
free you know and then I went to Bible
College for a few years and then my
properties we just like with rising and
a lot wow this is cool yeah
now I'm game rich I never would read
like that and then just refinanced him
yeah but do smart because I give people
around them hmm and then Vincent weepy
yeah and lease option agreements and
stuff and deal packaging um it depends I
mean we're not in 2015 that was when I
kind of really learned deal sourcing I
saw 256 deals in 2016 so I'm in a lot of
money in 2015
sorry 2015 from deal sourcing so it's
like I'd learn a strategy I go really
hard now I feel like I'm really
beginning to become quite seasoned as
like a big deal develop but yeah I mean
Jesus praise everything for sure
the moment you you the moment you forget
that your student is the moment you
start shrinking and if I'm growing a lot
but yeah yeah so what you do with your
noun sense of like education and
educating yourself
I spent over a million pound in the last
18 months on my own personal education
and for the education of my team about
what type of things are they be so four
months ago I dropped two hundred
thousand pounds with Grant Cardone
yeah
consul consultants business consultants
advisers going on even training programs
I love going on training programs
there's something special about want a
mom for sure and it is helpful because
you can get also training programs the
people in the room and the way so I go
on training programs as well I went on
like a business boot camp a few months
ago and you tend to still learn learn
quite a lot of things oh yeah I would
learn something even if I just sat on my
own for a day with no one else just
almost giving yourself just the time to
learn essentially get so caught in the
business a lot of putting yourself in a
different environment and just being
there do you know so when you yeah
absolutely and and I think that it's
also tax-deductible
yeah so I love the training courses an
expense so it's almost like I'm I'm
getting I can I can I can I can pay less
tax by learning and growing more yeah
and ultimately for me my big I'm
addicted to anything is growth growth of
the business growth in others growth in
myself I'm not trying to make it much
profit as I can yeah yeah okay
commercial properties yes you do yeah to
be honest a lot of stuff you'll probably
end up doing commercial properties all
commercial properties is is commercial
is easier in terms of the management
side of things but like these these
apartments you're talk about these
student apartments yeah to be honest
like you will probably depending on the
scale of the project and you'll just get
one tenant you're just ready to the
University yeah there's in big scale a
student apartments rather than you be
like I need to find students in these
rooms is but hey do you want to rent the
block off man
and you and then you'll have a business
renting off yeah yeah you know so so I
think it's just less hassle to say oh I
thought that was a point Anthony made I
mean because I everything I've been
doing just residential in search not
residue so we didn't know anything about
commercial and then every seven seconds
already know much bad then he's it's
great if it's well you could get the
Starbucks right now for dinner by years
alone yeah I think I think about
commercial as well is that it's so easy
to value a property based on commercial
yeah it's not commercial properties not
based on the bricks and mortar
commercial properties based on the
business so how much if you if you start
a 20-year lease with Starbucks for
instance it's the lenders will value it
based on how much the Starbucks paying
you yeah which means it's very
predictable that's what Ben was talking
about predictability so I think it was
really good and that you know we do and
I would encourage sometimes because of
the predictability of it and the safe
and uh solve it your return will be a
bit lower
yeah okay you can be but I'd rather
sometimes that then a higher return but
then having to be like oh my gosh I hope
everything's built things good to have a
mix of that you think yeah yeah
there'll be mixed juice there's some of
my four ticks are mixed yeah yeah and in
terms of JB's I know you said you're
open to new interviews but how would you
I'm you know there was so many people
but I want to do JB's with you how would
you separate the ones you do when
they're dealing with and how you don't
have to me oh dude I think that it's
just a case of for me it's it's all
about win-win so and every joint venture
that we do is different so it's just
relationship and that's why I say what
let's to spend it let's just spend it
out together yeah yeah
so yeah I mean we of course we have lots
of we have lots of people that want to
do a venture and we look we love doing
mentoring as well if you were on forge
I'm in the fortunate position where I
have got cash so I can invest in with my
own deals but then sometimes if I've got
a couple if there's a few deals going on
that's a good deal that's a good deal
I'd rather joint venture with somewhere
there yeah and I have my finger in all
of the pies yeah and just use my
and just do one that was Van Alden
awesome if you have the money why would
you join joint venture which is very
true
this is but that can be a trap see 2018
2019 and I've even said this I had that
okay so I used to grow becoming
successful I have to do a yeah yeah
someone don't you imagine I used to
eventually to a venture nobody's other
people's money then as I got wealthy was
double March luck into my name and then
in 2000 like eighteen I thought I don't
even warn other people's money I don't
want to give him a 72 the profit why and
I got to the point where people were
literally saying to me so I got a
million quid please can you vest it for
me and I'm like no I'm a and almost made
of all and I got so and you know like
this that I was like actually not only
do I not want your money okay but I want
to give my money to other people and I
actually started bridging my money out
and I was like yeah into 2019 I get I
gave over a million pounds to people
only Academy he's still just in cash
yeah and I'll have a charge on the
property but we see them looking at
deals and then aha and I'm the connect
Francis deal I'm gonna get bridging and
I'm like they're about to about 18% to a
bridging company know what forget it
have more money yeah easy-peasy
yeah and I was that cash rich and I had
you know a few million in the bank
hmm and I was just - and then when I
make Grant Cardone he absolutely kicked
my ass on this and he was like do you
want to be a billionaire one day I was
like yes he said you never never gonna
happen right like what he was never
gonna happen because you've become lazy
because you're using all your own money
you need you scared you create to leave
so he doesn't yeah it's exactly it is
about the same thing that got you
wealthy to begin with you know where you
were because sometimes I feel like it's
like a toothpaste tube when you first
get I think a toothpaste you just like
but then when there's a lot even through
Google with the last bit and I feel like
it's the same with money when you've got
a lot of money but then actually we've
got to be good stewards we've got it be
free we've got to be good with our money
we've got to be smart so so I probably
got to the ball
yeah whatever it's all good you know but
but but but but I I feel like afternoon
grime now I'm like actually no I'd
rather I'd rather ten deals going on and
leverage my knew you'd be part of it
yeah because ultimately it's going to
build my wealth more and I want for me
now I'm on a mission to is build up but
also help people and I think that me
turning down to events I know those
people coming from our China and so that
all people say might want to invest with
you and I was like how did I do that
and then they'd invest me someone else
and they would go wrong and I could have
actually helped me yeah yeah you know so
so so we've really to but it's just it's
just but I'm also really open to just
supporting you in like for me it's just
about everything has to be completely
win-win yeah where it's will and I'm
also on becoming much more relational
role in transaction also before I was
just like one of the fingers now I'm
like what's the person like you know and
it's more about relationships win-win
so but I think from your boy and best
thing is for us to just look at some
projects go out and then we'll just Eve
something all going begins to happen
yeah and also go out with it's already
right now but also go out with other
people you know and see what they've
gone you don't want to yes come on I
know on you're trying to mentor whatever
but yeah you know come out with me I'll
shave my projects but then go out with
other people see their projects and then
you can compare against you'll probably
see the mine are way better or if they
don't look better it might be because
the figures elsewhere are not actually
accurate yeah cuz my figures are
conservative but compared Stephanie
important man for to shed live on like
on joining up with people and doing
joint ventures because I think just like
everyone a special around footballers
and family just changing how how they
look at things like that they always
think someone's trying to gain something
over you know someone we trying to get
in a bunch of look you get this you get
this you're both happy
I think spreading that kind of message
and doing the end and showing the
results and like you said documenting it
and all that definitely like I want to
do and to show people what's possible
the people that was kept before see the
results come back mean ours I know what
you're doing it's open yeah get involved
they'll be like that's how are you busy
even my trainer business says people are
you trying to steal expensive courses
people it's like no I actually run a
free crash course yeah
first to show people what we do and
stuff many people want to be more and
for sure I'm passionate and if I think
so but like ultimately you've just got
to give value yeah everything's got to
be win-win and an every business deal
whether it's done with joint venture
partner is done with a buyer and seller
those don't have anything there's got to
be a happy buyer a happy Stella a happy
like it's got to be like nominee for the
long game yeah yeah any joint ventures
that I'm doing it's got to work because
I love it
I'll put it out there yes generally is
gonna just be the great I love other
other situations other people saying oh
really want to do a deal with me and
very well-known people famous people and
happy to vlog it and I've got deals but
I just thinking I could deal with
they're not perfect they're good but I
this needs to be really good yeah yeah
because I know what the doors it will
open and the exposure so for me it's all
about reputation yeah and I'm you know
people always hey but it'll look good
but but don't give any more reason to
hide yeah make their reasons just
clearly just jealous or whatever rather
than actually look what I'm doing
looking on helping look at the biggest
numbers don't lie yeah you know yeah so
that's actually why I wonder as old I do
something do a joint venture with
someone someone that you know that stuff
I can learn it so now I can end up doing
a joint venture with someone who has the
money but not the knowledge and I have
no knowledge I mean rather than just
been on the side of the joint venture
where you just have some money to invest
question oh so for anyone that's
listening to this the mob thinking oh
I'm going to come and pitch the pitch
Kevin like what are you looking for in a
joint venture partner I think someone
just just really knowledgeable he's gone
through the training who would get he
would get your approval or who would I
think you don't get your approval and
just just not - yeah just not know what
they're doing have years of experience
and someone who's actually doing it now
and it's got things going on now yeah
results that you can show me and I've
seen you've you've done and then just
just like mine it really motivated
hungry and proactive
just just to mix and match me but I'm
gonna we're doing the job in charming
that you're going to be speaking to you
every single day yeah well be done
what's next so why did you do this why
did you do that
yeah to be able to do that yeah you need
to be able to be involved for you also
for your learning exactly you know so I
think there's a lot of people out there
that have the knowledge and the network
and the experience wherever but don't
have loads of cash yeah and that's kind
of pokémon there's you hear me the
question was there's lots of people with
loads of cash yeah limited amount of
money on the planet you just need to be
trustworthy honest knowledgeable proven
endorsed maybe branded don't worry about
the lack of money get that stuff and
then the money would come I give people
money all the time to do deals yeah
that's one things I really want to push
on to footballers as well to show what
spot before I did this this like a whole
new world I didn't know really any of
this existed I know about dual sources
or I didn't know anything I mean I don't
and the amount of like possibilities
that are in property mmm dad we don't
know about it's crazy
you'll be bombarded with messages after
this I'm always reluctant to put it out
but I know that that's what you want
yeah greed the heck out of these people
yes
that's why I say you message me you know
you screen it and then you send it to me
do you still find deals by yourself
you'll write me much oh yeah all the
time
I check probably every morning but when
I get up I look around to see what's
around in my area different any
properties going on that was successful
or unsuccessful I want to see what's
going on within half a mile yeah tons of
learning or still looking for your
indoors yeah I am but then what I'll
normally do see how many partnership
with everybody I'm a collaborative
person I've got members of staff I've
got partners so what I'll do is I'll say
if I brought moving I'll then send it to
someone
yeah you know I'll even send it's like
my manager or sister no I'll just blame
yeah what's on Rightmove compared to
ones that you get from other people that
off-market a yeah tend to be able most
of my big deals don't come from right
booth but I'm still in one Buddha yeah
but I'm also on gumtree
I'm on open rent I'm on like Craigslist
anywhere everytime go pass the news
agents I'm looking for I'm just
constantly on the lookout like a dog
looking for a bone
you know me looking for my next deal and
I just think I ever be able to stop that
yeah but that doesn't mean the whole
thing away I don't see I don't see the
lead and then go view it as always
people involved yeah I do want to
improve on that one finding deals myself
yeah but you'll probably find is you'll
be like finding something but then
rather than you go and then booking the
pinger then you go looking at you you
say well that's interesting
and then sending it to other members
yeah yeah you've six months ahead yeah
you know in do sales no because you
don't you know and you know and so so so
do that as well look for your own deals
send them around
you don't wanna become passive you don't
it becomes so passive it's just learning
in for me yeah yeah but there's so much
to it because this is finding the lead
then there's do the due diligence and
there's the buying process then the risk
assessing which is the most important
and there's the building and the
overseeing and the project management
then there's the revaluation the
refinance or the selling there's there's
a lot of stages and I think that you
should be as involved as possible with
every stone
yeah every stage and down the line it'll
probably you'll be at a point not not
probably definitely you're investing in
your putting money and you want to scale
and then people will be coming to you at
the moment you're saying I'm looking for
deals I look for but but soon you'll
have so many deals coming out of your
ears
mmm-hmm then you'll be saying actually
you know what I'm looking for some
finance yeah Thomas I know I could just
use my own clients
it's say say you do a project and go
over tom scales before yeah but say you
could do a project successful what you
really want is you want them people to
be saying to you and this is what I
wanna wear Horning at YouTube right now
you're saying I've got money but on in
deals and only deal sources only joint
venture partners right you want to flip
that round by getting so many deals
becoming so successful then people are
saying to you cuz can I just don't
mention with you that's the end goal
yeah but by the time you get to that
point you'll already be very successful
in proper - yeah you're with that person
with the proven record you're with that
person you're on endorsing on my days
good yeah he knows his [ __ ] man he's
been out with me
yeah and people were saying to me oh
yeah yeah absolutely you know and that's
where I was wearing this business greed
is never a good thing like but for me I
have people all the time that come to me
and they say like oh is this person a
good god you think you're doing them to
a mentor they're not gonna be like oh no
do we do with me or what do you use
yeah man there's so much money the sound
people sometimes even think oh I'm
trying to sell none to undo it you know
oh I'm like I'm just trying to make
money actually yeah and I'm just trying
to see other people make money actually
and there's this when you come from a
position of so much abundance people
that have got desperation written on
their forehead they're desperate for the
next deal they're desperate it's like
actually they don't really turn people
away they'll turn the sellers away
they'll turn - I've mentioned or they'll
turn big builders button but when you
like you know what I've done this before
I'm them a thing yeah I'm I'm good
I'm branded I've got hues of people I've
got a lot of money I've got a lot of
deals actually what happens is when
you're in that abundance more multiplies
more multipliers multiply that with you
yeah and it in terms of so as a company
that really so a property company when I
probably run across time so maybe six
weeks yeah so in terms of now
business-wise it's very small or what
steps now so I take to stop growing it
to growing the business or in it yeah in
terms of just maybe just how you said
having people do certain things for you
and how would you go right now you're
learning so much everything you
you're learning I wouldn't I won't be
employing anybody I wouldn't be because
you don't meet her yeah I think the
focus for you now needs to be over the
next three months it needs to be seeing
lots of opportunities deals mm-hmm
going out on the road with me and two
other people yeah you've been having van
cynic right yeah the guy with me go have
a couple other people over the next few
months see opportunities well the
business is there where they like the
business is only gonna grow when you get
a policy to make sure that you generally
means no I wouldn't I wouldn't worry
about trying to employ a team we'll try
good because also you always want to be
replacing yourself so before you can
replace yourself you've got to get good
or something first so you know so when
you start taking good of stuff every
month finding deals I mean you know okay
I've done this before and I'm good at
this right now I'll get someone to do it
but why now you have nobody took so much
yeah so get good of it and then start
replacing PA system wasn't and and yeah
replacing yourself
plan for you here's what I would say
next three months here's what I think
you should do in the next three months
number one let's let's do a day together
on the road and and I'll leave you to
make chase that and make that happen
okay you can chase some Amelia at my
manager baby's number as well but let's
do it let's go on the road on that quite
regularly and he will probably be closer
to home as well I won't be ones I don't
think nowhere where ever I love you I
love you that's number one number two is
I'm gonna send to you personally I'm a
freaking expensive board game it's the
most expensive one oh it's about 70 quid
nobody's like a tenant but I'm gonna
send that I'm gonna send you a copy as a
gift cash play 101 so if you just give
myself Amelia on the team your address
get that's about to you what's that how
many pay is that normally it can be it
can be to me my wife play hold on
or it can be public up to six I'm in my
double play yeah might be dad took me
down I know you want to get you dad to
the point where he's making a few
thousand a month yeah through probably
different strategies yeah so just keep
keep encouraging him it's great to have
you
I know you dad got there for the first
like five minutes I'll be thinking in
the first five minutes I think I know
what you think I'll eat you thinking
what on earth is my boy dragged me to
yeah yeah you want that he's open-minded
closed-minded he's coming deppoh calm
yeah yeah yeah you be watchin you like
the hot man oh yeah good eye he's yeah
literally
you changed my cell lock yeah phone from
being there hundred percent like now
he's on the news on the phone call an
agency right cookies on that sorry on
these first cool got closer Corina enter
inside yeah you've got clothes on it's
personal isn't dope the worst thing you
can do is not ask for help when you get
stuck yeah that's it yeah cuz you're mu
get stuck yeah you know but when you get
stuck ask for help whether that's my
team and stuff whether it's finding
people on the Academy though look like
an tonight for instance
people will help 20 seconds this
mannequin you stopped the Train on the
Academy so yeah gonna be sick so that's
core so I think the next few months will
get you down through the training
because you can make sure you all the
training in three months if you got the
time yeah yeah 101 I'll send you go out
for a day with me and go out for a day
with at least two other people that are
experienced that are on the academy that
record I can I can even or maybe you are
posting to a post on the Academy that's
not pages all cutely some people and
then forth fillet last thing is just go
through like with a tooth comb and be
very very diligent link I put this out
and you just just go through it yeah
you're probably of a lot of messages
which is a good thing I mean you wanted
that yeah but that's just part of the
activity of those students as well see
what opportunities you get yeah
be very careful yeah because everyone
thought to make a quick buck mm-hmm you
know everyone just wants to make yeah
hold on hold on
what was the three-year plan the next
three months I think between three and
six months so I from the spring towards
the summer I think we need to begin a
deal in the back yeah that should be the
plan yeah cuz that's fast still yeah and
it might be that happens quicker than
that it might be that happens a bit
longer than that I think that should be
the general so by the summer you should
have a deal big deal where you it's in
the bag offer accepted whether it's a
joint venture it's not a joint venture
you could do it alone but make sure
you've got support yeah yeah whatever
yeah yeah
fine and then I think from from the
summer to the winter it's just going to
be a case of completing the build yeah
that's gonna be fine yes and get out
there once a month with a yellow heart
heart see the progression be learning
like crazy
yeah the deal needs to be an all your
money in and all your money out yeah
leaving you with a passive income
perfect plan yeah no that's good dude
give me a shout appreciate my TV shout
and it's real um yeah so much about the
branches
[Music]